like because i i think one thing that uh
one aspect of our job which
uh which we wouldn't have as like a
normal office worker for example is job
security like if you want to get in this
field and you want job security
i think we have negative job security
like how hard it is to like uh you know
you apply for like credit cards or yeah
anything long-term financing yeah i want
to know your annual income yeah it is
literally impossible to give a number as
a youtuber yeah it's like it's like the
most roughest the mystery is like
all right so i'm not going to be honest
with you it could be like
1k or it could be 20k or 100k so
basically the whole spectrum of
money it's hard to go to a banker and go
well i i think the next video might do
really well
just just like i'm pretty certain so
like i'm thinking maybe like this
there must be like the banks when they
first you know met youtubers they must
thought they were like horse gambling or
something like that
i got a lucky fool about number seven
next week man i'm telling you man
there were definitely like money money
laundering yeah yeah
this is this is the this is like this is
what we think like nfts are now right
i remember the first time like having to
answer that question like when applying
for like our visas and stuff like that
and i'm having to explain who pays us
i'm just like well
google
so and so like you said and so they're
on employment so you work for google
you're employee of google and you're
like no
kind of leeched yeah
yeah yeah and then we have this thing
called patreon where people pay us to uh
so excuse are you employed to patrol
it's like every like red flag is being
ticked yeah yeah yeah like yeah like
like when you're a doctor right
your job is secure
oh yeah yeah unless you go around
killing people you're pretty good like
you you know it would be rough not to be
employed
i just realized how on paper like how
similar we must look to like a drug
dealer
laundering money if you go to the
checklist so you get you just get money
put into your account sweat when i have
to talk to accountants man it is it is
the most stressful thing because they're
just like i can see on the zoom calls
the look on their face while i'm telling
them what i'm doing yeah just like
okay i thought i find it hilarious is
the situation of a drug dealer going to
a bank to get a loan it's like
it's like so do you so you sell drugs do
you work for the farm
no
i haven't got the drugs yet so this is
kind of like a
collateral yeah
drug dealers what do you do i'm a
youtuber
i provide a service
i guess it's a timely topic well not
timely it's still be like three weeks
late but the whole twitch thing as well
right the earnings oh yeah oh yeah yeah
people finding out how much creators
make what was your number joey i don't
even know
i was like probably twenty thousand or
something on stream so well no no you
were you you were you were in top ten
thousand ducks
we're both league hell yeah let's go
i hope i hope our youtube earnings get
leaked before the next year's episode so
that this age is poorly forgotten
oh my god that was that was funny
it was seeing it was funny seeing the
reaction because you know as somebody
who's been doing this yeah i'm i was not
surprised of seeing these numbers no
absolutely not um and also i try to tell
i always try and explain to people you
know the reason why let's say xqc is
earning seven million and getting all
this absurd amounts of money what it
seems like absurd is that
you know that if if that's the the
number one person in music is making
billions of person tv is making millions
right the number one at anything is
making [ __ ] tons of money yeah if you're
in the top hundred of something in the
world you're probably making a lot of
money i mean if someone was bothered to
leak it you'd wouldn't you have a
suspicion that it might be a lot of
money yeah yeah and also also
there's no point leaking something where
the number one sport is making like 15
if
for for this to exist right for the
system to exist where let's say that
creator you watch who is making a
hundred viewers yeah which is all of us
at one time yeah right we were all that
one channel i i distinctly remember for
for a year or two where i only got like
40 to 100 views on twitch which i was
very happy with yeah absolutely
for that person to go to make income and
and somewhat support themselves
there has to be a person at the top
who's proportionally making a lot more
depending on the audience size right of
course yeah it's a system that works
is it super fair that some people make
[ __ ] hundreds of millions uh
it's up to you you know i mean all i
will say is that those from what i saw
there is a lot more money on youtube as
opposed to twitch
from what it seems the amount of work
you do as well especially yeah i mean
the the the youtube uh like the top 100
youtubers are probably making a lot more
than the top 100 twitch streamers
yeah i understand yeah yeah i don't know
how it works i think so as well um i
mean you sound like mr beast there's no
beast on twitch
and all the ones that are on twitch that
involve money and gambling are extremely
sketchy yeah very very sketchy
definitely and uh that's a whole other
thing the whole gambling side of twitch
is [ __ ] yeah that's a whole lot like
he likes i mean youtube inherently is
a massive platform much bigger than
twitter it is much bigger than twitter
so you know yeah like some of these
channels that are uploading you know god
knows how much darman's making yeah i'm
sure he makes xqc's uh revenue in one
day yeah he's from eastern sponsors
right like it's it's totally crazy and
we
i am still shocked that people are like
top influencers earn how much you know
when there are some of them that are
going around in
private jets lamborghinis and all this
stuff right it's you know i wish i was i
wish that was me [ __ ] it out i mean i
mean i'd love to buy my whole the all of
wales you know some of these guys have
the gdp of wales i'd love to to
reinvigorate the economy yeah yeah yeah
i mean are we surprised how much
hollywood movie actors make or how much
some of the top music goes oh yeah
yeah and then like and then
like this is like a new entertainment
platform of course top creators are
going to be making millions you know
we're not at the billion stage yet
because we're not as big as the other
entertainment industries but these are
what the top creators are making and
that's just
we are just like a baby mode of the
entertainment industry you know of like
the rest of the uh establishing the same
industry
i'm sure when like massive hollywood
actors were first you know starting to
make these like massive loads of money
and that got found out i'm sure the
general public was like wait these
actors make how much money like it's the
exact i feel it's the exact same thing
it's like it's such a new thing now and
it's also just so unprecedented because
it's so different to anything that you
see on like tv or radio or anything like
that because it's just three guys trying
to justify their income the conversation
yeah pretty much
thing it's like it's most of it's public
anyway yeah that was that was it was
especially weird yeah which thing is
that most content creators sub count is
public and this income was somewhat
known or close to node right you could
easily have like kind of guest yeah yeah
right so it's like quite odd why is it a
surprise it's quite weird but i i i
think the people that
i think a lot of content creators were
like a common people are still surprised
about it um i think the people that were
surprised about it were people who
weren't involved yeah yeah watched
twitch or weren't
you know touching it at all yeah yeah
and i saw we were being like i'm gonna
be a twitch stream like yeah right good
luck
that [ __ ] is harder than youtube
yeah
twitch is [ __ ] hard right yeah yeah
uh and it's it's the search algorithms
aren't nearly as optimized as youtube or
tick tock or something um yeah well i
mean it's it it just shows that you know
there is this is a growing industry
right now like this is it's it's weird
seeing how youtube and twitch have
evolved as time has gone on yeah and
seeing it go i think that's where the
different lies and where they get their
perspective from which was the
difference between say twitch streamers
and youtubers versus hollywood
celebrities or big music artists is that
you know we a lot of us
started off in that exact same position
as everyone else you know it is an equal
playing field so we don't get we didn't
have to go through these auditions
or you know go get signs by this massive
music label or anything like that we
grew organically buyers by ourselves and
i think i think it's just the shock that
someone who
went through that avenue is able to earn
that much right but but it's also like
you know i i think
what a lot of people don't like to give
credit to is that a lot of the creators
who
are earning that much now right at some
point or another they were where they
were working full-time hours on top of
whatever else they were doing yeah on
something that wasn't paying them yeah
but that's the thing it's like years
yeah i feel like twitch stream is again
it's like a lot like youtube is where
like the biggest difference is that i
think a lot of people see them more as
like this person that's on the same
level right it's like a lot more
personable it's just like the dude
across the road
whereas like you know no one views
[ __ ] like johnny depp is like the guy
right kenny west could like burn a
billion dollars and people would be like
oh kanye
it's different right and there is this
weird kind of dichotomy of how they with
i
expect the standards of traditional
celebrities to to
influences and stuff